all right on to the next question from
physiostrength nyc
what would you say is the most pragmatic
and valid way to objectively measure
fatigue
so i'm not actually going to answer this
question
perfect well it's a i will but it
may not be the answer you're looking for
the most pragmatic
and valid way to objectively measure
fatigue is probably not the best way to
measure fatigue
um i say that because there was
a meta or not a meta-analysis there was
a systematic review
that came out not not all that long ago
i want to say 2016.
title was monitoring the athlete
training response colon
subjective self-reported measures trump
commonly used objective measures
colon a systematic review and the title
kind of gives the game away there
so based on
the measures of stress and fatigue that
we have
it seems that subjective measures
tend to work better than objective
measures both
for predicting subsequent changes in
performance and also for
predicting the deleterious things
that tend to come with excess fatigue so
here we're talking about
increased injury risk risk of
developing infections or illness
which can happen with with over training
so it seems that for the most part
subjective assessments
of perceived energy perceived stress
perceive fatigue
perceived mood tend to do a better job
of
actually assessing athlete fatigue than
objective measures do
an exception to that might be if you are
purely an
aerobic athlete heart rate variability
seems to be a pretty decent indicator of
fatigue
in aerobic athletes
almost all of that research is either
looking at aerobic athletes or
like heart failure patients there's
i think one study on strength athletes
and it was looking at
using hrv to kind of like assign
training frequency and
not so much how well
it tracked with some like gold gold
standard measure of fatigue which
i'm not really even sure what that would
be um
so yeah objective measure is not that
good
subjective measures pretty good um
if you have some sort of sleep tracking
device
if you're interested in something
objective that could be pretty decent as
well
so a
a leading indicator of
fatigue and over training that often not
always but
often kicks in before you actually start
seeing drops in performance
is sleep quality and duration start
decreasing so you're really tired but
you can't sleep
you're waking up more frequently in the
middle of the night takes longer to fall
asleep etc
generally if you're tired you're
supposed to be able to sleep like a baby
or you know maybe you're just someone
who has sleep issues all the time and
you still just have sleep issues all the
time
but if you generally sleep good and you
generally sleep better when you're
fatigued
and suddenly you're even more fatigued
and you're suddenly sleeping worse
that is that is
a marker of fatigue and possible
overtraining
that you can quantify objectively if you
have some sort of sleep tracker device
but you can also quantify that
subjectively
i mean like most of us know if our sleep
quality sucks
um or at least have a pretty decent idea
of it
so yeah um
most most pragmatic and valid objective
thing you can use
hrv if you're an endurance athlete maybe
some sort of
of sleep monitor for anyone else but
for the most part subjective measures of
of mood
and perceived fatigue and stress um
seem to be more useful for most athletes